[Music]
this is games that you should know by
heart
I'm Grandmaster Denis wash this time I'm
going to show you one of my favorite
players
Richard Rockport but he's not my only
favorite I like Jabba too so but the
occasion that I'm showing their games is
very important because there wasn't our
mageddon if somebody can tell me what
our mageddon game was played recently
that was so important for the World Cup
yes yes so there was an Armageddon game
between Levon Aronian and MVL and that
would decide who will be the qualifier
for the candidates as you mentioned and
now the reason I'm showing a few of
these few of the games of report and
Jabba is because the line that will be
featured in that Armageddon game is none
other than the Java report variation and
that's why I'm showing you these first
games so you get used to those positions
okay so report plays what move
what is favorite number one move
usually d4 yes it's it was an advantage
to know the ecosystem because from these
zero zero you can tell it's not going to
be b3 today which he plays just like
Java does simply is d4 Knight f6 and now
he will decide where he will put the
bishop
once the guess where will he put his
bishop right now
some people say Bishop f4 anyone else
once twice Bishop g5 this time is Bishop
g5 so this is the trump offski d5 III c5
c3 now if you have an eagle eye you can
tell that this is basically a position a
Slav position reversed where the bishop
is outside the pawn chain and we have
this regular pawn structure
beiiy is known to many as one of the
best prodigies but in this match Robert
actually beats him knight c6 92 and
let's try to make a natural move with
black here and that's what Mary plays
'if I've yes now this move is not good
for a simple reason that black is not
developed yet so this was a good game so
we can learn that we shouldn't open the
position when we're black because we had
done a lot of Tempe and the easiest way
to get an advantage when you have a
Tempe advantage is to open up the
position
how did report open up the position he
takes e5 Knight takes e5
F 4 would be a bit too aggressive also
it would weaken the EEP on which we
wouldn't want to do
Knight f3 yes natural moves are
sometimes the best that accept three not
accept three there should be seven and
chess is a tragedy of one Tempe and
report asks one question before where
you would Castle and what's that
question
what is the move that asked that one
question that you're a little bit late
Bishop b5 check before you go wondering
where your king is headed King f8 would
be admitting that the plan didn't work
so Bishop d7 and how can report voice
force the issue Bishop takes Queen takes
d7 in 95 so Robert just asked before you
go how about I stop you from castling so
the Queen could maybe try to go to be 5
but that would lose a pond let's say you
played Pina 5 but if he plays queen bee
5 white could consider either like Queen
B 3 still annoying or just taking on f6
and Queen takes d5 he played Queen f5
and now report asked again check where
are you going and apparently nowhere cuz
97 would run into Bishop takes e7 and if
the Queen takes on e5 Bishop takes e5
white is a pawn up he's going to castle
and black is totally lost if the King
takes then the King is just stuck in the
center so he plays King f8 now white
finds another very good move here Bishop
takes f6 because if Bishop takes then
what happens
and after King g8
yeah 97 just means the pawn king g8 and
Knight takes e5 and there's no way they
can bother our King because it's very
safe because of this e3 f2 structure so
out of necessity black played G takes f6
because queen takes f6 is ill-advised
due to 97 check g2 except 6 and now very
good Grandmaster move comes
NIDA three job is done black didn't
castle he has a terrible structure and
in long-term black has just totally lost
because eventually the d5 pawn might get
weak and also the f5 square which we
will soon see rook g8 Knight H for
defending the g2 pawn also emphasizing
that that f v square is going to be his
fini six Queen c2 now long moves are
always tricky okay that's not a legal
castle that's the King moves to g1 is
and there is a nasty little trick here
that where you just set up yes the rogue
g4 and there's no way to stop the loss
of a night but rockport saw that and
just played Queen c2 emphasizing I'm
going to jump on f5 and no one is going
to stop me doing that d4 in a very e is
usually a tactician and he knows that
this is the last moment he can stir up
some trouble otherwise he'll just be
positionally lost so white plays g3 if D
takes III one might even consider
castling say takes Queen takes F 2 and
for the pawn white will be able to bring
the rook to e1 and after Knight f5 it's
just disaster for black Queen d5 do we
want this Queen to stay active on d5 or
not not really so you'll just chase it
away efore Queen c4 and here report
plays a very good move
liquidating move but a good one
did anyone say something
Queen e2 then he might have d3 or queen
take C to D takes c3 him Queen b3 okay
he found this brilliant idea of b3 now
this seems to be losing upon but report
realized he'll get it back the benefit
takes long castle and the king will just
munch on the C pawn later f5 trying to
get active see you can see that there Y
is trying really hard to stir up
something but by now it's too late
because the night is a monster on f5
right now rogue g6 how should we
continue with white d7 yes rookie six
takes takes king c2 and now white will
just gobble up this pawn and we'll have
one extra pawn also a better structure
with the 8th King takes c3 b5 King see
to roof d6 rook d1 notice that report
would be happy to exchange pieces as
he's a pawn up any endgame is winning
for him
mostly pawning games locate 6 H for
broke up six Queen d2 monroig dieter
okay six kingdom 3-0 g4 he's slowly
mobilizing those bones c4 takes takes
King d4 he doesn't want any kind of
funny business cuz if let's say Kings
takes e4 black might consider getting
active with King g5 king f4 and nobody
knows nobody knows but he didn't want
any of that and played King d4 okay for
thanks now he v f3 he's slowly moving up
his pawns and because they will be
connected this position is that lost
four value
rokay six Ruby 467 g5 rookie 6-1 and now
reports made a brilliant break how does
he do it in this position g6 would lose
upon just too many ponds
h5 that's not really a pawn break it's
me maybe helping the idea of a pawn
break be six and the idea of tix then f6
and the pawns are unstoppable
eventually they just turn into to pass
pawns and that's over so very resigned
okay so the other game is I'm going to
show from report is against re re on d4
Knight f6 Bishop g5 he likes playing
this line d5 III 97 97 I'm not a big fan
of because it's very passive on d7 so
Norwegian player didn't quite grasp the
situation the knight would be for
example e 6 is better let's say an ID to
c5 c3 knight c6 the night is just
happier on c6 on D 797 night of 3 c5 c3
g6 92 Bishop e7 Bishop d3 castles a4
well the idea of a4 is for example if
white will play h3 I'm really
unnecessary move then black could go c4
and maybe eventually b5 after rook b8
let's say b3 b5 and this is
approximately even but report doesn't
want any of that and plays a for b6 and
do we know report as a peaceful dryish
player no he goes for the full point
which is the most aggressive move we can
find it looks actually it usually looks
passive but it's an aggressive move that
report found in this
hint it's a queen move Queen c2 that's
too active
it's okay active moves are good in
general mm-hmm Queen B one creamy one is
actually a very clever move because it's
multifunctional it hits on h7 but it has
other ideas
what why it's other idea to do this
before yes exactly
so if Bishop d7 white can just play b4
and gain some space he didn't want to
play a long positional game though so he
gone he had gone h4 86 we should Pat for
not g4 and now if we know that Rockport
is going for mate you might find his
next move enterprising and fun and also
good what did Robert play here
no-no-no Bishop h7 check ig5 he's going
for the win but okay sorry didn't want
to get made it yet h6 g5 obviously would
be suicidal because there would be a
check King h8 it's Tigs g5 and this is
very threatening and after let's say
queen c8 there's a very nice finish in
this position I can like yeah Bishop g8
and even though black can try to stop
the mate with Knight h6 queen h7 would
still make black it's quite a nice mate
but okay sorry didn't want to get made
it weird
you know I'd have six in here report
again comes up with an original idea
actually I think he was kind of
visualizing what actually happened later
on
Bishop g6 that's too creative it's
interesting but it's most likely a bit
too much well on which file we're trying
to play with white on the edge file so
in the near future king e - that's close
but not the f3 no but King e2 is close
it's close enough you didn't want to
decide yet if he wants to move the king
or not yeah Rock h3 pretty creative move
really in the style of Bronstein setting
up a trap and asking his opponent hmm
are you going to fall for it or not well
we shall see
Queen c8 night DF 3 and now Knight e5 is
kind of coming and that's annoying
so Tory took the bullet and took on g5
how should we take it back
bond takes obviously 94 and he found
this Knight irritating so he took D
takes and now report found an original
solution here
King D - yes the Queen swings from b1 to
h1 with deadly threats now black could
try to play f6 which you didn't do g6
and after Queen e8 what would be the
nice finishing touch
rook h8 takes check and we thank our
opponent for the cooperation
he played g6 instead so he continued
with our plan Queen h1 f6 and now he
played again another very good subtle
move and I think that's the one that
Tory might have missed it's white to
move and win
locate seven with the idea locate seven
deadly and black is helpless against the
slow burning threat of Queen age six
Queen j7 mate there's most likely what
Tory might have looked at was check King
goes to f7 and the King might run away
from he ate through the eighth but after
Luke age seven you can take this well
that doesn't help you clean h6 and mate
there's no way to stop the only idea to
stop the mates from g7 is rook f7 but
then just rotate it mate so we can see
these unusual ideas that keep popping up
and Robert is famous for that but
there's another guy who's famous for
original ideas and that's Joe Baba
the four the five is the other way to
reach this position you often do because
the Slav is very popular these days but
then they play Knight c3 Knight f6
Bishop f4 but anyways it will transpose
Knight f6 Knight c3 d5 Bishop f4 and
whenever I see Knight c3 and Bishop f4 I
always think about the Java report duo
because they done so much for this
opening report beat suit off ski in the
Olympiad with this very variation and
Jabara won many games which I'm going to
show right now against ponomaryov c5 III
C takes it takes now this is actually
you think about it is a reversed
chigorin excuse me a six and even in the
chigorin run black plays the climb he's
going for speedy development how can
white go for his speedy development in
this position yeah yeah yeah Bishop d3
is very nice and that's what Joe baba
did our report played it was Knight f3
and that was his game against suit off
ski so javathread Bishop d3 because they
always like to experiment in their pad
line knight c6 Knight G to e6 I'm not
thrilled with this e 6 move because that
Bishop will be a prisoner on C it
forever
Queen d2 b5 black is trying to play b4
but white stops that after castles and
plays a3 we should be 7 and we can see
that this Bishop is pretty unhappy you
move at one square that's not really
great Bishop would be happy to be on g4
age three castles rookie 195 rook the
in b6 and even though this night looks
funny on c3 and it is funny usually a
pawn should be pushed and this Knight is
happy on c3 but it stops from white
developing a center which would be
useful but in general we can see that
everything that Jabbar did was pretty
harmonic right nigt rook FC 8 and now
fireworks started how did you bhava
start fireworks in this position think
about it before you check the move
whenever are you looking for sacrifices
always look for undefended pieces yeah
not f5 and for gifted technician like
Java it's nothing to find an unprotected
piece so prana Mario who was a feeder
World Cup champion and feed a world
champion decides to take tonight he
would have also tried to move the bishop
that would be a different idea
he takes rook takes e7 we should be 6
and now Jabara makes the move of 2016
pretty brilliant idea and unusual
it's not hard to notice that the
Brooklyn e7 is kind of trapped so if Y
doesn't do something quickly you'll be
punished
yeah pleasure page six
an astounding move which should get like
five exclamation points because it's not
every time you just put your Bishop on
pre and it's perfect
it's perfect you can use any engines
five of them it's still going to say
this is a brilliant move and this is why
I'm all awed by Jabba's creativity that
he can find spectacular combinations
like these so King f8 wouldn't work
because Bishop takes g7 if King takes g7
then Queen g5 checked and why just takes
the knight
but if King takes e7 then Y can take on
f6 and I wonder what would happen if
black would take on f6
what would happen if King takes of sex
always look for undefended pieces Knight
takes d5 and after Bishop takes d5 yes
and Knight takes d5 would finish the
game because takes it's a double attack
and the undefended Queen on b6 is taken
so he took Queen takes h6 rook takes c3
Queen g5 check if a queen takes f6
you're not bothered by that Brooke and
surprisingly even if black would play
rook c7 I can just take on f5 you can
take on e7 if you'd like well then I'll
check Mitchell age 8 and that's a pretty
nice mate so out of desperation for no
marios took on d3 C takes D 3 but
actually black cannot stop white from
playing the simple plan of rook e1 book
takes a 6 let's say Queen d6
we're not troubled daruka still taboo
because Queen h8 is made otherwise rook
takes e6 just wins the game
and now another job of a report
variation d4 Knight f6 Bishop f4 a6
black is stopping night b5 ideas a move
that is often played by Javon report for
example if black plays a 6 both report
and J Bhabha plays Knight b5 night a six
and A three trying to stop black from
playing Bishop b4 after c6 Knight c3
there is no Bishop b4 which would be
annoying and the point of this night b5
idea that this knight on a six is pretty
clumsy
and it doesn't really function well
there so that's my stuff chenko played
a6 and you and as my you have noticed
this was played in the Bronstein
Memorial Bronstein who was kind of the
forefather for both reports and Java and
look what Jabba vadas in this game
III g6 and now he plays a move that
Bronstein would definitely be proud of
how did you baba continued in this
position h4 yes Bishop g7 and without
hesitation all three of them would play
h5 not h5 BAM rook takes h5 takes Queen
takes h5 and this looks like a
coffeehouse game but Java knows what
he's doing because these light pieces
will be so strong in these positions
that they can compensate for the
material deficit that White has so let's
see how it continues c6 Knight f3 8 6
castles 97 green h2 now
jabo is cheeky just like Braunstein
he's kind of hinting on Bishop c7 which
would be a cute little queen trap
obviously black as a ground master he
doesn't fall for that plays Knight f8
which is a bit weird Knight f6 would
seem more natural
I'd have faith Bishop c7 mean d7 there
should be 296 Bishop e5 well it's a
close up position so in close up
positions what type of pieces you need
Knights how many nights does white have
to the maximum out amount so that's
great and that that's true well you're
not going to promote a pawn yet route
gauge 1 f6 Bishop g3 Nagi a gracious
offer by black that white accept no 91
and where is that night headed c5 Castle
93 Rina 5 for sure before night c5 and
you can see that in these close up
positions
let's just function much better than
Brookes so I would wouldn't say that
like it's better anymore because the
nights just feel so dandy in this
particular situation you need 7 G for
trying to stop black from playing Bishop
f5 in g6 Bishop c7 b49 a4 and then other
night is going to be 6 this is just
paradise for these Knights d5 Knight b6
rook a 7 we should be six rook e8 at for
complete domination
those Knights just dominate all those
rooks and that Bishop on C is just
terrible
not f7 and when you're trying to develop
an initiative the first thing you should
think about which one of your pieces is
not playing at all
wedge bishop the bishop on e2 so let's
help that bishop how can we help that
bishop how can we help bishops in closed
positions open the position g5
sacrificing a piece not a problem that
takes d6 bishop h5 greena 5g takes h6
and this is something that Grand
Master's realize they don't try to they
don't like exchanging good pieces for
bad ones like this exchange would be
just great for black because that rook
wasn't doing anything at all anyways so
G takes age six
he'd rather remove this defender on g7
which is bad but it's a defender rookie
7h takes g7 takes f6 f takes Knight take
CA 98 and the next move is another job
of a brilliancy its job OVA to play and
make wonderful move
and what's Jabbar actually really
brilliant at is imagining things at the
moment the black king can hide away on
f7 and potentially on g6 but what if the
g6 square is blocked by a black piece so
Bishop g6 indeed was played rook takes
g6
that would just lose because of Queen
age 8 king f7 or okay 7 check and we'll
mate soon enough takes takes here mate
but he took on with the Queen check on
h8 and rook f1 and that's why
imagination is so important in chess the
king can't move to g6 anymore because a
badly placed black Queen and after Queen
f6 rook takes f6 would win he played
King g7 which runs into green f8 mate
okay so we saw to Jabba report
brilliance is in there variation now
let's see the game of this year 2017 d4
Knight f6 Knight f3 g6 Bishop f4 Bishop
g7 so let me set the scene our own Yin
was dominating this match against washi
but then it all petered out to be a draw
mvl had some chances in the tiebreak
sessions but then Aronian equalized so
this game went all down to the
Armageddon game where black has four
minutes to White's five minutes
mvl decided to choose the black pieces
in iranian goes for the java java report
variation Knight c3 d5 and as we pointed
out earlier
white can force something here
what did might play in this position no
not age 4 not this time not b5
yes so black didn't play a 6 actually
didn't have time to play a 6 because II
four was threatened so he couldn't stop
white from playing that b5 and this is
just like we're very similar to Robert
Bailey game and many games played by Joe
Vova III Castle h3 c6 Knight c3 actually
they played this very same position in a
previous tiebreak game where Aronian was
winning but this time what she came
well-prepared and played Knight c7
Bishop b2 b6 we've seen previously in
the reports valley game what happens if
black opens up the position early right
it was a debacle for black so MVL
realizes that this Knight seats weak
Bishop f4 is not just roses and ginger
el and he decides to develop a
slow-burning initiative on the Queen
side
she plays Bishop e7 Misha page to c5 a4
a5 what's probably Aronian was planning
to play a 5 and put some pressure on the
Queen side but a 5 is a very good move
stopping all of these ideas now may I
remind you that if Aronian draws this
game's this game he loses the match so
he must win somehow 95-97
takes takes Bishop g4 y 6 ok honestly
here blacks position is ok and apart
from this very ugly night on c7 his
position is decent and also we can feel
that this knight on c3 is
badly placed Queen d2 Bishop c6 I can
buy bolster this a4 pawn with b3 rook c8
92 obviously Aronian is conscious of the
fact that this night is pretty clumsy
there so he moves it to a better place C
takes d4 and he takes for the night b5
and actually if you're familiar with d4
type of positions this is kind of a
reversed kind of minority attacks a
takes b-52 9 takes b5 c3 Knight takes d4
and let me exceed four is a nice move
but in general and VL is aiming for
exchanges as a draw is great for him he
takes d4 a4 but I think if it was a
little bit too much it's not a bad move
but there was no need to rush with that
before this should be 5
Roxy 1 because in the long run this a
pawn might get weak hint hint
a3 Bishop e2 and now black plays Queen
c6 which she really shouldn't have he
should have taken on e 2 and in general
I think black is pretty much okay if not
better so he played Queen c6 and now our
own Ian takes his chances take your time
and try to find the best move in this
position
obviously this c3 pawn is a bit
backwards and kind of weak we can find a
way to stabilize the situation for white
might might even get some chances in the
near future to win this game
so the goal would be to find a move that
can potentially shield a spot on c3
yes Bishop b5 queen bee find Bishop d6
now I was live-tweeting when I was
looking at this Armageddon game and I
always felt that this was the critical
turning point after this
White will get the Bishop to c5 and to
be honest objectively now on white just
has the better chances because this a
pawn will be chronically weak and black
will be without any real plans rook c6
Bishop c5 rho k 6r okay - obviously
we're blocking that a pawn we don't want
that to move too much bishop queen c4 we
need to and now Bishop f8 are we
planning to take on f8 no not at all
King F 1 e 5 but now as you sacrifice
upon then we take and now I'd say that
White has the better chances maybe it's
not winning yet but early on has real
chances of winning but this is the
moment the game really gets interesting
because they're slowly running out of
time
King g7 kingi to bring your king if it's
an endgame and that's what the two
grandmasters do the fourth takes King d5
and Livan plays rook d2 but there's
another move that he could have played
which would be equally or maybe even
slightly stronger what other move onion
can play in this position
rook c7 would go for pawns but in
Brooklyn games usually you should aim to
have quality passed pawns and not taking
pawns and in order to have a good pastor
you have to give them good protection
rugby - exactly
he played rugby - which is fine but
rugby - might be even stronger as after
King takes d4 b5 and this pawn starts
running and eventually the a2 upon falls
and should be pretty good for white rook
D - King C for d5 but he chooses to run
with the deep on King takes b4 d6 king
b3 and now LaVon tries an idea that's
rarely seen the white king is kind of
using a letter and tries to walk the
stairs through h4 g v f6 king D for King
gage for King d5 and now
LaVon plays King g5 which doesn't spoil
anything but he has a slightly better
move here which is also winning but
maybe it would be more forceful g4
that's kind of similar
yeah g4 is a good move but there's
something more direct that LaVon could
have done
d7 yes
because if King e6 we can sack because
you can't take all of those because we
clean and if you move the rook
I think I'll defend that pawn and even
if you don't defend that pawn that
waiking is so active most likely that
position is also winning even though in
general four against three is a draw but
I wouldn't be so sure if this is a draw
this time King g5 King g6 but remember
this position was played with only
seconds on the clock and both is under
great pressure but now on MV I will
start fighting like a lion g4 takes
takes and he plays rook a5 which is a
tremendous fighting move setting up this
f6 trick so wide defends the e5 pawn
rookie to f6 King takes g6 Ruby g8 can
get six rook takes g4 and now Levin
finds the only way to break through it's
white to move and get winning chances
what
f-five check yes creating a passport he
six and now it seems that the pawns are
unstoppable and it's very difficult to
find the move but the computer says
there is one only one move that could
have drawn for washi in this position
which which would have gave him the
chance to play in the candidates it's a
very weird move but if you notice that
the White King is in trouble and
actually MBL noticed that but he chose
the wrong way to attack black the white
Kings position yeah he played whoo Kate
but the move is rook a a4 and the great
trick here is that if white would push
the pawn like a crazy person then it'd
be check check mate so it's something
that white would want to avoid so he
needs to check first look at four Luke
takes F for six F for if you push the
pawn then black Queens so white has to
take King takes six and it's a draw at
best for white so that's why there's a
good reason to keep on fighting on
because sometimes you might get a
miracle chance now and we have played
bouquet eight which was a decent try but
not good enough because Aronian found
the only one in this position
notice that our passed pawns on e6 and
d6 are about to reach
the level where they're worth a rook so
I played rook f1 check look at for only
move
how did Levon Aronian continue you take
first and rook takes a to the order
matters but also remember that you're in
time trouble so the clearer it gets the
better
so he took immediately and took on a two
now because it's now very clear that MB
I can't stop the pawns from promoting
he's seven rugby to Queens and after
this it's a technical win for our own
young king III King g5 of d5 check yeah
they have like seconds left in this
position yeah this is just lost
objectively lost it doesn't really
matter if you know it or not
yeah but it's still a win and king e to
his plate
notice that aronia posted his screen on
f5 so he covers the see two squares
after checks King D 2 and no more checks
on C 2 because the well position well
White Queen would be three check in D
for nice little subtle move again
because if black would start checking
which is the annoying part then the King
can move to b3 and there's no rugby to
check again just because of this Queen
d4 move rook h3 Queen b6 Queen f6 King
gay to check double check rugby three
King c2 King A one one last trick I
should be finish up the game Queen takes
wouldn't be that great because that
stalemate Queen a6 check that's what our
only on plate and MBL congratulated
Levon Aronian of becoming a candidate
that's how our own young one against MVL
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]